Kris Jenner is not holding back about
her past spilling all the juicy details
about her love life with her kids go boy
I'm really excited for my kids to see my
legacy video because they'll have that
forever and who knows maybe they learned
a thing or two about their mom that they
didn't know before
in the latest Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kris sits down with Scott
Disick and her daughters Kim and Khloe
Kardashian to watch a special video
tribute about her younger days mom are
you hooking up with him yeah oh my god
you're such a [ __ ] now we know where we
get it from and then we went back to
Caesars house and lo and behold Caesar
came home to surprise me so what
happened well it wasn't pretty
did they get into a fist I'm not proud
of it actually Caesar tried to grab his
sweater I think he ripped a hole in
Roberts sweater I didn't want to ever
hurt anybody's feelings I just wanted
some qualities or was that a towel
thanks to Scott the kardashian-jenner
family can rewatch Chris's life story
for years to come
I cannot believe Scott made this legacy
video I think it's so sweet and so sweet
so much I think we think we know about
mom but we really don't
[Music]
you